so good afternoon and welcome welcome to
Patel Chapel it's a
my name is Sharon Kugler and I serve as
the Yale University chaplain and a
committee member of the Yale well
Committee yell well offers a framework
for instilling habits of wellness and
students and developing a strength of
well-being and emotional intelligence
Yale well identifies and supports pilot
programs that use the expertise and
interests of faculty students staff and
alumni these projects teach skills not
always taught in the classroom today
Yale well is delighted to bring Edith
Hall to campus to speak on how ancient
wisdom can change your life Edith Hall
is a professor in the classics
department at King's College London she
is a leader in the study of ethnicity
class and gender in ancient sources of
ancient theatre and the continuing
impact and use of ancient ideas in world
culture she's the author of several
academic books and editor of many more
she also writes for the wider public
thank goodness so some things I can
understand her recent book
Aristotle's way was reviewed in the New
York Times Wall Street Journal and Time
magazine particular review that spoke to
me was written in American scholar and
it it said in clear patient language
Hall deftly weaves threads pulled from
this daunting range of material into
lessons that pertain directly to the
dilemmas of modern life
we're told that Hall first encountered
Aristotle when she was 20 and he changed
her life forever
one of the books strengths is her tone
of unmistakable sincerity I think we're
in for a treat
professor Hall will deliver remarks and
we'll have some time for questions and
answers afterwards please join me in
welcoming Edith Hall thank you very much
that's a very warm welcome and for the
invitation to come here I haven't been
to Yale for several years and I always
like coming here and especially to
Professor Emily Greenwood for organizing
the whole thing yes I am a practicing
Aristotelian I admit it quite what that
actually means in everyday life is an
interesting question this is a sort of
picture that I do have in my fantasies
in another life I might have been a
student at Sir Aristotle's Lyceum which
was somewhere with beautiful garden
where scholars and students would meet
and study with Aristotle it's really the
first what it is it's the first thing
that we can recognize as a university as
we know it in world history in that it
was a teaching institution for people of
approximately undergraduate - sort of
postdoctoral stages it had a wonderful
library Aristotle had an extraordinary
collection of his own books and actually
the way that he arranged them was
provided the model for the great library
at Alexandria but something even more
important he surrounded himself with
colleagues not just in in philosophy
because he was a true polymath the
master of those who know as Dante calls
him and so he had scholars of science
and maths and physics and chemistry and
biology and zoology as well as
philosophy and especially local history
constitutional history and they gathered
there but at five o'clock in the
afternoons or it's sort of sundown or
it's not invited the general public
who were interested in talking about
ideas into the Lyceum every afternoon
and would talk to them he had a huge
commitment to public outreach in fact
published a great many books in very
short form short treatises which what he
called the exoteric books which just
means the opposite of e so Tariq instead
of inward facing its outward facing so
in very many ways he is apart from
anything else a fantastic role model for
anybody in higher education in the 21st
century the picture that put me on to
the Greeks as a child on to all of them
was in fact in a children's magazine the
one on the right it was called look and
learn I just thought I'd never seen
anything so [ __ ] in my life as those
guys standing around in the Lyceum
talking about great and eternal truths
and my delight in the mid-1990s when the
Lyceum was actually discovered during
excavations for the Athenian underground
train system and has been properly
excavated and although those aren't the
same flowers that bloomed there when
Aristotle was talking to his closest
colleague the great botanist Thea
fastest who I like to imagine planted
that garden it's still a very beautiful
place to go it's right in the heart of
Athens a little bit east of the
acropolis and much to be recommended so
I've been asked to talk about happiness
because Aristotle's entire moral system
has a goal in mind which is the
individual and collective eudaimonia
happiness which can't be achieved in a
long-term sense actually can't really be
achieved it has to be created and
recreated every day it's more of a verb
than a noun it's a way of life which is
why I wanted to call my book Aristotle's
way in a quite sort of Gospel sense it's
a way of conducting yourself
and it takes a certain amount of
certainly intellectual commitment there
is just one ancient picture of
personified happiness on this beautiful
vars in the British Museum but here we
have actually the rather more populous
view of what happiness is in that she's
got some nice jewelry she's probably
getting ready either for marriage or for
meeting her husband she's surrounded by
symbols of erotic love and luck should
be that is probably the popular idea of
what happen is and it may well be the
sort of popular idea that we have of
happiness happiness is something that
you're supposed to be able to get by
buying a foreign holiday going on a
cruise going to McDonald's to get a
happy meal going to a cocktail at happy
hour and so on or just getting to be
incredibly rich or just being madly in
love all of those sorts of things this
is absolutely not what our settlement
Aristotle it was a commitment to trying
to be the best possible version of
yourself you could possibly be that is
maximizing your whole potential and in
particular as a moral being as an agent
and by working on yourself to try to
make yourself a better version of you
than you were before you started
thinking about ethics and he is
absolutely probably gives you absolute
promise that if you do this in a sincere
way and are very honest about your
failings and work on them that you will
get to be a lot happier than you were
before you did it and I can only give
you the empirical evidence of my own
life that I discovered this 40 years ago
when I was about 21 and it's worked for
me I think I am as happy as I could have
been given all the cards I was dealt you
know the different things that happen
bad luck good luck all the rest of it so
I've decided to write this book only
about three years ago actually because
my agent who had previously written
a fairly standard history book about the
ancient Greeks for said why are you
always going on about what Aristotle
would have said what Aristotle would
have done could you please just write it
down and I did in about ten weeks it
didn't except for the last chapter which
I couldn't finish and I'll tell you
about that later
it's he literally just said just go and
tape yourself talking and thinking aloud
because I think the world might like to
buy this and I'm your agents I'm
interested in making money okay where
we're going to start the Aristotelian
system of ethics is complicated it's
also an amazing network that comes out
to encompass not only moral behavior but
biology your attitude to your material
environment politics your attitude
towards your fellow citizens and it's
really quite hard to find an entry point
and you'll be pleased to hear that after
going to quite a lot of schools to talk
to 15 year olds and 14 year olds about
this I've decided that the best entry
point is the political animal it's that
we're all animals I'm not suggesting for
a minute that your intellects are no
more developed than those of 50 both but
I find it easiest to start with this so
this was actually a completely
revolutionary thing to think in the 4th
century BC that I am a homo sapiens I'm
an anthropologist that means I'm an
animal that was not the way the Greeks
thought at all
the ancient Greeks thought that they had
been made specially by the gods and they
were very different from animals and a
lot of their structural thinking is
about being not animal not wild but
Aristotle says no we are animals were
just advanced ones and then because he
is actually the founding father of
zoology I think there any zoologists in
this room but you have to read Aristotle
if you do zoology he invented the entire
system of classification according to
different modes of reproduction
different modes of ambulation
respiration
kind of thing what he did was beginning
his question what is a human and how can
that human be happy by saying what is
different about the human animal the
political though on which was misquoted
by President Trump in an altercation
with the Pope a couple of years ago but
never mind what is it different about us
as a as Oh on an animal from all the
others then we will know what it is to
be human by a process of elimination and
he spent two years on lesbos with his
friend Thea thrusters who was from low
score seventeen years younger than him
this is a Victorian zoologists fantasy
of them inventing botany on the one hand
the zoology on the other as far as I
know there are no lines or giraffes on
lesbos but it's a very nice idea these
are just some of the many animals the
book I recommend if you've never read
any Aristotle before the book I actually
recommend you start with is his history
of animals it's a joy to read it's not
difficult it's all about wonderful
stories about all the birds and bees and
insects and the horses and fish that he
was very expert in and had talked a lot
to hunters and game keepers and
fishermen about and he classifies them
and these are just some of the animals
like asses and bees that he was
particularly keen on there's an awful
lot about horses and just before I go on
to the classification and the human
animal I'd like to say I'm not going to
talk much about politics today at all
but one of the great advantages of
Aristotelian thought is that he is
absolutely compatible with and by a lot
of people treated as the founding father
of an environmental approach he's the
perfect philosopher for 21st century
green politics and this particular
scholar who's a Turk called Osgood Orhan
who are being in touch with because
someone told him I was showing his
picture a five foot has written a
wonderful article
explaining how arizona's approach to
particularly production and
sustainability is something that is a
very good model he doesn't believe that
we should ever produce more than we need
he thinks that things start to go wrong
when we have more commodities than we
need
he also fascinatingly to me I found
right there in one of his other he wrote
four treatises on animals that has
survived one of the other ones that
survived the first ever example of a
human of an animal species that has been
made rendered extinct by human activity
and he's very sad because the red
scallop of the lake on lesbos no longer
exists the fishermen have told him
because of over dredging the face of the
lake so he's actually already sensitive
to those issues but he decides and this
is a very very simple summary I'm aware
that there's at least one professor of
philosophy who knows far more about
Aristotle than I do in this room I
should say I did not do my doctorate on
Aristotle I did mine on Greek tragedy
these are the things that he thinks most
distinguishes Homo sapiens from all our
fellow animals we like to live in
communities but there again he says so
do some others like bees we can develop
that he's terribly interested in
friendship strong friendship bonds with
non kin and effect they may be more
important
kinship bonds than those with biological
kin they may be a much more beautiful
relationship crucially we can reason
enquire deliberate and plan this is an
extraordinary capacity which as far as
we're aware no other animal shares with
us fully and being able to reason think
about the future make decisions and
particularly ask questions about the
world just everything that we do here at
university that continuous process of
one
and inquiry and it's particularly
important I mean the famous opening page
of his metaphysics is that all humans by
nature yearn for knowledge all humans
not you know one race or one gender it's
humans desire and yearn for knowledge we
have this special capacity which in a
slightly mystical way in some of the few
very mystical bits of Aristotle seems to
be linked up with his idea of God that
we actually become most near what he
imagines God which is an intellectual
capacity we become most like God when we
are fully activating our reasoning
powers because this is something very
special about us we can decide to and
acquire them decide to acquire them and
then go out and acquire them Tecna
competences skills we can learn to man
cars we can learn to analyze what
happinesses is actually cause it just
another technique another skill or
competence and all of human life is
about acquiring different competences
and different specialists have different
ones though there are some tech9 we all
need like personal hygiene or ability to
cook a decent meal
we very importantly in his works on
memory can recollect intentionally and
purposefully he has noticed that dogs
for example can remember other animals
have memory it's quite obvious they do
if you take a dog for a walk it often
knows where to go the next time animals
remember what time meal day their meals
will be served they remember humans who
are kind to them they remember humans
who aren't kind to them but can they sit
and say do you remember three years ago
when we went on this walk that there was
a rainbow right or shall we try and
remember where all the water holes
when we were here last year probably not
though I know that the certain of very
advanced animals we are now discussing a
lot more what they're capable of humans
ability to activate conscious memory is
for individuals an extraordinary power
and I will come back to that later and
very touching Lee he thinks that
laughter is very human which means it
must be important he's very interested
in laughter he knows there's bad true
laughter but actually laughter is an
incredible gift which he thinks only
humans can do unfortunately we've lost
his famous treatise on comedy so we are
community dwellers we have these strong
bonds with people who include non kin we
can reason enquire deliberate and plan
we can aside to acquire competencies we
can recollect intentionally and we can
laugh that's a fantastic set of things
and Aristotle actually says that if
that's the case then that makes us more
responsible than all the other animals
he says that human beings can be the
noblest of all animals because of these
credible gifts but it also gives us the
capacity to do a thousand times as much
damage as any other animal and I think
that particular principle that it's the
gift it's also the responsibility this
makes us responsible for all the other
beings with whom we share the planet and
I'm much happier grounding all of this
not just in all the environmental
catastrophe we're bringing on ourselves
but as we are by dint of our
intellectual capacity we must be
responsible for all the others it's it's
it's absolutely essential right
we are also born with two kinds of
potential and the word Aristotle uses
for the ten shots when the most exciting
words in Aristotle is Dunamis Dean Ami's
it's actually the word that dynamite
comes from and I'm very upset that
Alfred Nobel chose that word when he was
wanting to label a highly destructive
explosive with substance because I would
like to have a positive dynamite this is
the dynamite that could make the whole
of the human race as far as i concerned
far happier and that is this every
single anthroposophical fill their true
potential if they could do that then our
chances of great happiness would be
serious dynamite right we're born with
two kinds a potential every individual
you'll notice I'm starting from the
individual the inside of the individuals
head this is something that is very very
different from the way you start to
think about life with Plato for example
it's very anthropocentric you start with
quite a subjective principle rather than
starting with the city state and working
downwards you start with the anthropos
and work upwards through partnerships to
build the city-state so we've all got we
were all born with the Dunamis or ease
even from the moment of conception the
Dunamis to develop into an adult human
rather than for example a mature oak
tree or a swan that is we would now call
it we have our species basic DNA kit
right he called it
this special Dunamis he thought that it
was imprinted somehow by the father
semen on the woman's internal matter he
didn't quite get the relationship
between female the between mothers and
DNA but he got this idea that it was in
there already from the minute of
conception but then we've also all got a
Dunamis peculiar to ourselves and that
might be to be a great gardener parent
poet cook politician pianist singer
mechanic engineer doctor teacher or
something else but absolutely everybody
has got something that they really ought
to be growing up into being because they
will be good at it right and that is not
determined by what their parents do it's
simply not it's much more random than
that and the fundamental first stack if
interning in terms of trying to become
an Aristotelian happy person is to
identify what it is that you will make
you fulfill your thought become the very
best possible version of yourself and
then fulfill it easier said than done
and I know I have I have very young
adult children and it's one of the
hardest questions of all and society is
telling you all kinds of things
pressures all kinds of pressures on you
to be famous or to be rich or to be
obedient or to be this that the next
thing or to take over your father's
company but it's crucial to try and
listen and sense as hard as possible
just momentarily during momentary
actions during chancing cancers and
experiences what it is that gives you
really good pleasure and I don't mean
eating or sex I mean what activity in
your daily lives gives you true
satisfaction that you would like to
develop to actually get better and
better and better at it rather than just
enjoy it as a sensory experience it's
also very important I think to be
patient I did not figure out what I
wanted to do till I was 27 at all good
parenting and mentoring is of course
essential and we don't have enough of
that nowhere near enough parents even in
highly developed worlds where people
have got the luxury not to spend their
lives merely eking out a subsistence to
feed their children even where we have
that luxury the amount of bad parenting
I see just in two
a wrong pressure right instead of
letting the child finds their way and
the way to do that I think is by maximum
exposure to lots and lots of different
things not by forcing people to have
hundreds of violin lessons if they
plainly don't like the violin but I
don't know a lot about it but I'm
assured by neurologists that there's a
huge amount of evidence that the human
brain is not fully wired up until 25
it's actually not fully wired up which
means that forcing people who haven't
decided what they want to do before what
they're 25 is likely to have unfortunate
results neither does not fit with our
current pressurized examination programs
and so on but I certainly know in my own
case I was about 27 when I really
realized what I was good at and what I
wasn't good at and was able to decide
what to do on that strength once you've
found out what you want to do you gonna
have to be able to communicate directly
and effectively I'm actually really
going through the chapters of the book I
try to cover most of Aristotle's really
important books and his rhetoric is one
of the most influential text books on
persuasion in world's history but is the
first extant one we've got but what's so
important about it was that his teacher
Plato was very much of the view that
learning tricks as he saw it of speech
learning how to persuade people was
something that led to very specious
sophistic arguments people spin
doctoring people being able to argue
away from the truth towards untruth or
worse towards really unpleasant agendas
but Aristotle opens the rhetoric and
again he's very good he's rousing
openings and he says I do not understand
why we train our fellow humans to be
able to defend themselves physically
right with weapons or their bodies
and we do not train everyone to be able
to defend themselves with that tongue
which in everyday life he says for
ordinary people is far more important
being able to make a coherent argument
defend yourself further your interests
and those of your dependents avoid
defend yourself against persecution
advance your own interests and indeed
simply deliberate well and I in my
chapter on rhetoric actually do they do
it on a job application with a CV you
can actually reduce everything he says
in the rhetoric to four principles and
I'm very pleased that in English that
gets to ABCD isn't that wonderful it
doesn't work on being told by people
translating my book into Arabic and
Greek but hey and that is audience until
you think about who is it who I am
trying to persuade what the emotions are
like what the emotional situation and
relationship is between us you are lost
and I know that I know this very very
well as somebody sometimes has to read
200 letters of application for a single
one year lectureship or something at
King's College London people who have
not bothered to find out who will
probably be reading that letter don't do
very well so audience research whoever
it is to brevity as short as you could
possibly be for the content clarity at
all times and that's much harder to
achieve than it sounds
and then delivery and delivery can be
everything from how you open an email to
whether you being a starving student go
and hire a well-cut suit for that job
interview right delivery is the fourth
element but it's incredibly important
when I get emails that say hey prof. I'm
not well disposed towards the person who
has opened an email with April I don't
particularly want distinguished madam
either but that is if an hour
a mean between these two and we should
go on to that but to fill our human
potential this is one of the greatest
gifts really that Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics gave us is the
ability to deliberate effectively and
that is to make decisions and we all
have to take decisions all the time
far too many actually in modern life in
terms of choosing between consumer goods
and so on hardly anybody is trained at
the right time which I believe to be the
server early teens in the basic
principles of good deliberation and this
means that people take disastrous
decisions precipitately
and without thinking through all the
consequences that is what happened with
brexit as a collective decision but this
is what happens when somebody leaves
their spouse because somebody has told
them that their spouse has been
unfaithful right the next day this is
not a good way of deliberating and I
have been rather brutal with Aristotle
here because he's taking some
information for granted from free vyas
writers on counseling and deliberation
he also wrote a treatise on deliberation
which has not survived but implicit or
scattered in his work on decision making
are these eight principles I'm leaving
out the ninth which is don't deliberate
with women or with when drunk because
obviously you wouldn't want to do either
of those thank you whoever laughed ok
first take your time now that has become
it sounds so obvious but when I was a
young thing before email when we
actually had to write a letter and put
it in the post you would write the
letter saying I'm resigning and
emigrating to Australia forthwith or I'm
leaving you cutting off our children and
going to a convent I would write that
letter I would put it by the front door
I would go to sleep I would get our
like throw it away in the bid and I felt
much better because I had done that with
that emotion what do we do now we bang
off that email how many of you have done
that don't my husband will not let me
answer emails after 8 o'clock in the
evening because I have almost always had
a glass of claret by 8 o'clock in the
evening he simply won't let me all right
so that's why they had the Delphic
Oracle in edge of Greece because it took
10 months to get an appointment by the
time you've got your appointment at the
Delphic Oracle the putt did City the
state that you wanted to declare war on
right had probably sent you a lovely
present right it's very very good
principle but more importantly even in
that is verifiable information the
amount of decisions that are taken on
bad information misinformation lies
slammed just bad facts we invaded Iraq
about past Britons on entirely false
information that we were presented with
by Tony Blair entirely false information
that decision was taken on in Parliament
if you your best friend says that your
boyfriend has been kissing someone else
do you believe him or her
you probably shouldn't because if they
your best friend they've already got a
vested interest in your emotional life
they're the last person to believe
actually what you should actually do is
go and ask the person involved these are
two very extreme examples but you know
what people do not think about it you
investigate precedents what happens when
NATO invades Iraq or Afghanistan or
anything else let's look at history you
then look forward you're using this
brain you calibrate likelihoods all
possible likelihoods you write down
every single possible likelihood if it's
a serious decision of how everybody will
react what might happen what might be
there and you still won't get them all
but you can try
you have to factor in random chance
there will be likelihood you cannot
possibly anticipate definitely but there
are things that might well happen the
example I give in the book is if you're
arranging a wedding you do not know if
you live in Britain whether it will rain
or not you simply don't know but you do
know it's very likely which means
therefore that you have an alternative
venue for photographs indoors supply
some umbrellas and have extra hairspray
for the bride right
uuuugh factor in randomness as far as
you can you consult disinterested
codeine liberators now because I was
speaking at an Ivy League university I
now I don't have to explain the
difference between uninterested and
disinterested I do actually to most of
my students at some point you don't want
somebody who's an uninterested in your
your plight because they won't go to
sleep and not listen but you'd want
someone who has nothing whatsoever to
gain or lose from you choosing either
way alright nothing and that will not be
your best friend it might be a
specialist marriage guidance counselor
it can be very difficult to find
somebody completely disinterested but my
word it's important and you can actually
pay people to help you make decisions
who have no personal investment you
consider consequences for every single
party concerned even leave spitting up
with somebody have you been only being
out with six months will affect groups
of friends and parents siblings possibly
right you think you have may not you may
have to discount it it's not as
important enough because it will affect
your happiness not to make the decision
you're going to but you have to be
prepared for the consequences on
everybody and lastly be prepared to
chuck it all in the bin and start again
and he's very big on this you must be
open to new data and prepared to read to
liberate in its light and it can be
actual just new data like what will
actually happen to the
customs union our role in the customs
union you know things we can know or it
can be that the actual situation has
changed and I'm not going to go on about
this much but one of the reasons I am
happy to do business with Aristotle even
though in the first book of the politics
he says that he is perfectly capable of
tolerating slavery and he thinks women
can't deliberate because I know I could
supply him with the data and the
persuasive rhetoric that would change
his mind
he is absolutely committed to constant
revision of constitutions and
relationships it's it's it's because
several examples of this that in the
light of new evidence interestingly and
I always want to tell the NRA this one
of the examples he gives of things we
used to do in Greece until we decided it
was a bad idea was bare arms in the
assembly right we have learned to stop
carrying weapons around in the city with
our fellow citizens it didn't work ok so
we stopped it and he gives many many
examples actually the beautifully what
he cites as what the best bit of
evidence about when it's noble to change
your mind it is not in constant right
it's the sign of a proper moral agent is
of tragedy called the philic TT's where
it's a very brilliant tragedy morally
but as a young man calls in the
autonomous who is told he's a soldier
that he has to go and take a poor old
man in agony of an island where he was
long ago dumped in agony because he's
needed again because only he and his
magic bow come and the Trojan War and he
must just go and get him by any means
necessary
and Odysseus who's very crafty in this
play forces him to go through with this
as his orders or but Neoptolemus when he
talks to the old man here's his story
here
his terrible pain this is a really
grueling pain screams in pain so speech
after speech he says no I can now see
this would be an immoral thing to do and
Odysseus tries actually highly
utilitarian arguments like the greater
happiness of all the Greeks at Troy if
we can get rid of the war felony she
simply won't do it sorry Neoptolemus
will not do it and promises philip tt's
that he'll take him home and look after
him in his own home in his old age and
it's an incredibly beautiful moment
because this young man stops doing what
the father figure tells him and becomes
a man morally and does the right thing
in the light of this new data and I just
love the fact that Aristotle who adored
the theater is using that example but to
be happy you have to do one thing that
is very platonic on a lot of ethics he's
very different from his teacher Plato
you have to know si se out on you have
to know yourself this is just a 18th
century engraving of a young man not
quite sure how to be happy and a sort of
cherub appearing with a tablet that says
know yourself but you have to start with
your virtues and vices the actual
technical name for our Satine I think is
virtue ethics which makes it sound
really poncey and off-putting virtue and
vices even worse it sounds like
prostitution and drugs rings but just
bear with me
it just means good qualities and bad
qualities all right I just
unfortunately the words virtue and vice
are very loaded
Aristotle bless him gives us in his you
Demian ethics an actual question are you
ready for your questionnaire on yourself
okay but just before I go on to it we
have to just make it clear that this is
not a dualistic system where you have
virtue here and vice there and all those
Stoics and Platonists and some
christians won't like this it's part of
the Aristotelian system that meant I
could embrace this virtuous these ethics
wholeheartedly instead of saying there
is anger and then there is non anger
anger bad non anger good yeah
or there is carnal desire bad you know
celibacy virginity purity good instead
of that everything is on a spectrum and
you want to head exactly for the middle
of the spectrum people have often said
to me including a couple of very famous
Aristotelian philosophers they can't
believe someone is so emotional and
passionate as I am which I am I'm
Priscilla - all those things can be an
Aristotelian and I thought to say to
them it's because I'm all those things
but I had to become not a thirteen-year
because I couldn't deal with a system
that didn't allow me to have an
acknowledge and sometimes think highly
useful things like anger or revenge or
desire what you're heading for is the
middle so he's very interested in the
whole nexus around anger and envy and
revenge of course having too much anger
is a bad thing too much younger woman
your anger inappropriate ties with the
wrong people you will hit your child
when it's your boss that has been
yelling at you
right you'll have anger that is not
properly controlled at the right person
then though you have on the opposite end
of that spectrum no anger and are sort
of firmly of the belief that anybody
incapable of anger cannot be an
effective moral agent they can't be an
effective moral agent they can't look
after themselves all their dependents
and we will never be happy you actually
need to be able to get angry to be happy
the point is that you have to use it to
get yourself into court if somebody has
smashed into your car and broken your
legs or if your child has been bullied
it's your soldier that helps you it's
the general
it gets you gives you the energy to get
up and act on the anger when you have
been damaged
and he's absolutely clear that people
who can't get angry at all will not make
happy individuals or effective citizens
so with that sort of spectrum and the
idea of going for the middle here's just
some of his principles from the new
Demian ethics she gives you a table so
you could go through them you can think
how do I feel about money right now you
don't have to tell me what you what your
answers would be but if you're not
honest with yourself it won't work you
must know yourself if you're not honest
you can't work on it and then get the
fruits of happiness yeah so there is
financial sense and integrity
there is avarice which means you go
around tricking other people and being
obsessed with money but there is a
deficiency which is just being stupid
about money
which means anybody can exploit you and
that leads to very diseased
relationships you need to be able to
stand up for yourself with integrity
about your money very closely allied to
that is how much should you give away
okay he really actually doesn't usually
tell us which way he's tending on these
things
IRA sort of really hates mean people
people do say mean with money you say
tight don't you you know what I mean
people who will not give any money away
especially rich ones he hates them I've
often wondered whether his father who
was a doctor never gave him any pocket
money or perhaps philip of macedon when
he hired him to teach aristotle
Alexander the Great didn't pay him
properly he really hates meanness with
money especially in the rich he thinks
generosity is absolutely will help to
make you happy especially if you can
afford it
but he's extremely worried about people
who are prodigal with money again
because he says not only will they lose
all their money so they can't look after
their dependents and themselves but they
will be gullible and able to be
manipulated which will lead to
problems in again in relationships right
if they're seen as a pushover that will
make people think they can exploit them
and the whole set of relationships
becomes more and more Dean's disease
this one interests me because very Greek
masculinity
you're supposed to boast right all those
warriors in home yes boasting is
supposed to be good but he says no
there's a median which has just being
very honest about yourself if you know
you good at something denying it
it's actually false modesty and in its
way a fault that sort of doesn't and
with this is quite interesting because
humility and foe self denigration it's
very much in our culture right but
actually I think you can lead just
problems if you know you're good at
something and the certain task comes up
it's good to be able to offer it
confident knowing that that's something
that you're quite good at it's also very
gendered thing in that it's much easier
for men to say I'm really good at this
this and this without being seen to be
what would be the word women are much
more easily accused of being arrogant
and boastful I love this one so just
getting your daily manner
are you a friendly person do you for non
people to suck up to them or you just
extremely rude I'm cooperative we all
know people of all those extremes if you
are on either extreme our subtle
suggests you will be happier if you
learn just to be friendly and the same
to everybody obsequious again
groveling behavior no no no but
self-respect is fine but don't get too
arrogant if I got this the wrong way
around I have haven't I sorry my vices
are the wrong way around self-importance
McNamara see pettiness
deviousness on one end gullibility on
the other but there is just simple
practical prudence in the middle and you
know what it's just you think well this
is all so obvious and how sensible yes
it is a lot of Aristotle's ethics is
just glorified common sense but when it
comes to things like revenge and envy
which are some of the hardest things to
control in life I think and I think this
is particularly appropriate in academia
where as we all know the passions run so
high when the stakes are so low you know
tiny sums a travel grant I bought
somebody's once decided not to be my
friend after 25 years because I'd won a
travel grant of 50 pounds or something
that they hadn't got these are very very
very bigger difficult ones and I had to
be very very honest when I did this on
myself my my own greatest faults are are
precipitate Merce wild extremes of
emotion I can be very rude I admit it I
do tend to do it up the hill to
superiors rather than down the hill sort
of bullying uphill if you know what I
mean but I've certainly done it in
inappropriate ways at times but the real
killer for me is I'm extremely
vindictive picking an argument with a
line manager boss who because he's got
power
even if he's trying to exercise it in a
good way you know just because I can't
you know I have problems with authority
even when it's being exercised and I had
I've had to learn I have made myself and
it has made me happy and I have fitted
better in since I stopped being quite so
automatically uncooperative with
authority but revenge has been when I've
had to really work on I spent a very
great deal of my life
harboring my young life grievances which
just looks you in the past again there
are s total says
people who have no desire for revenge
cannot be proper moral agents and it's
very honest about this so if someone has
maliciously damaged you or your child or
your dependent or your loved one then
actually and this is where we do leave
Christianity I think you do not turn the
other cheek if you're an Aristotelian I
could never I could never do that I
think if you deserve recreation and
public acknowledgement that you have to
admit damage then it is perfectly
legitimate and I found this much much
easier to work with the trouble is when
it then takes over your life that you
basically spend all your time brooding
on all the horrible things that have
happened to you because people are jerks
let's face it but so you can't you're
not free of it and I I learn with
Aristotle you know that really living
well wellness fulfilling myself having
the happiest life I could is in a way
the best revenge if somebody wanted to
do you real damage and doesn't want you
to be happy
then just going away and being happy
regardless of what they've done do you
see what I mean but anyway I won't go on
about that anymore because you have to
do your own advanced ethics how am i
doing another five minutes I haven't
really got much time he's credibly big
on intentions as the test of ethical
action that it's not the consequences
but it's the intentions he's very
interesting on when it's okay to lie he
thinks that the default position for
everybody's happen as his honesty for
very good reasons one is that he wants
you to be an authentic authentic or a
person who is true to yourself which
means you're going to be the same all
the time to everybody
you'll found your true person and if
you're the same all the time to
everybody then you can't be lying to one
person and right there is a true you
with truth so you will be happier
but he says obviously if somebody's
about to kill your family and a lie
would get them out of prison then you
tell the lie I mean it
and I think I found this very helpful
bringing up my children instead of
punishing them for a lie
we've always sat down and decided was
the person you were lying to could they
have helped you if you've told them the
truth or were they trying to hurt you
kids are quite capable of this quite
capable of it if my kids lied to me when
I will always do everything I can to
help them then I won't be able to help
them very effectively if I don't have
the right information on the other hand
if somebody you know stranger asked them
to get in to the car and they said I
can't I've got to be home in two minutes
when they didn't you know I would reward
them for that lie I would think thank
heavens they can think on their feet and
defend themselves
it's the same with omission Aristotle
was the first person we know of ever
this comes into the Catholic theology
but don't ask yourself at the end of the
day did I manage to keep my nose clean
keep out of trouble
but what have I actually done with all
the opportunities for helping people and
doing good and I thought this has been
very very important to me it's very very
easy to just comfort yourself at the
fact that you've kept out of trouble
especially once I got tenure I once
you've got tenure and you've got some
money and some security if you don't
speak up for people who haven't then you
are actually irrigating a very important
responsibility from a very secure
position so I get that is how I assess
politicians I don't say did they manage
just not say anything racist today it's
like what have they done and I find the
cult of rich people and celebrities who
do nothing with those positions deeply
upsetting I haven't got time for equity
but I'd like to I haven't really got
time for any more of it actually but all
of this expands out into relationships
friendships and the easiest way to I'm
just tantalizing you you do want to know
that the Greeks are very very keen on
Aras tatl at the moment because of his
general ethical principles this
the graffiti up in Athens weather
unbelievably poor at the moment where
he's saying but she did poverty is the
parent of revolution and crime he did
say that and in felony key there on this
thing called the 700 euros protests that
700 euros a month is the absolute
minimum you can live on in Greece that
the organization's took poverty action
they do it at the statue of Aristotle
and Thessalonica is not lovely that I'm
going to just end with potential I have
left all the way through politics but
I'm fascinated by this is Martin Luther
King's last sermon in his own church in
Alabama on New Year's the New Year's Day
before he was shot but he actually takes
the idea of potential and makes it a
reciprocal Universal thing and this ties
that with omission and Commission it's
not good enough just to fulfill your own
potential right unless you actively try
to help everybody else fulfill their own
potential then you're not fulfilling
your potential right and that is in a
sense an advance on the Aristotelian
Dunamis position and he said I don't
want you to forget he said to his own
children that there are millions of
God's children who will not and cannot
get a good education but you will never
be what you ought to be until they and
what they ought to be and that I really
feel I can feel Aristotle's head north
nodding in absolute agreement it's not
enough to go and be the best possible
you because the best possible you
actually means helping other people to
be the best possible then that's it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]